I want you to tell us first how you got
it on to the screen because it just
seems so improbable that even a
character as big as Molly could get the
support and the cooperation and the
interest of everybody to make that film
thank you
Thank You Pat I am gonna fess up I
really did not know of Molly Ivins I
grew up in New York in LA and by the
time I was of age to read her columns I
was out here I had gone to school out
here in college and so I like I said I
was you know grew up on the left coast
and the other left coast and so I really
didn't know who she was I think I saw
her on Letterman
in the 90s and I knew she had george w
bush shrub the little bush which i
thought was hilarious
so i really didn't know who she was my
friend who became my producing partner
James Egan and I wanted to make a film
together for awhile and so we'd been
looking for something so I'm gonna pass
that part of it over to James because he
really is the guy who got this all
started Thank You Janice and thank you
all for coming this afternoon for us
means so much to us when you make a
documentary to have an audience so thank
you so much for being here took us close
to seven years to get this film made but
it all started with the angles sisters
not related to Janice who Allison was a
friend of mine when I was teaching at
USC and she had seen all my films and
she said you have to come see my place
Oh God she wrote a play and so I went
and the red-hot Patriot with Kathleen
Turner at the Geffen and I I laughed
every minute I was so moved and I you
know I've make films about social
activism and I'd never heard of molly
ivins you know how is that possible and
I went backstage and I said to Kathleen
Turner and aunt Allison we got to make a
documentary and Kathleen Turner said yes
yes definitely do that and so we got
that early support and I said to Janice
you've got to see this play it's so
important that what this we get Molly's
message out and you went to the play so
yeah James called you have to go see
this play and I said why and he said
it's closing don't ask just go so I went
and I left my ass off through the entire
thing
and that night I got home and I googled
her till 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and
last you went down that rabbit hole
I'd YouTube oh completely and I I
couldn't believe it and I I called him
up and I said in the morning I said
what's up he said nothing's been done I
said nothing's been done he said nope
meaning and documentary there was just
this play so that was we got through
Alison angle we got to Molly's
gatekeeper her chief of stuff Betsy moon
and she IMDB James and I and said oh
they have credits there for real and so
we got we she put us in touch with the
estate which she left half of her estate
to the Texas observer and the other half
to the ACLU yeah and so in that period
of waiting for the green light we knew
we needed a Texan and so we both had a
mutual friend and as you can see the
Texan kinda you think somebody has to
represent for God's sakes yeah so we
James and I called her and and and what
did you what do you tell bank gang
pressed me they said you have 48 hours
to say yes I called them the next day
and I said I'm in let's do it
did you set out to to make a documentary
about a journalist who happened to be
Molly I've or was it was singularly
Molly whether she'd been a journalist or
a firefighter would it have been the
same kind of approach just because of
who she was I said to make a film about
the person you see on this screen
she was larger than life and it was all
about who she is she happened to become
a journalist she fell naturally
backwards into journalism and because of
who she is in what she had to say and
her ability to speak truth to power you
know it was her humor her humor is so
brilliant and so but she had such a big
heart also because she was a woman who
really came up at a time when it's
called the snake pit she broke the glass
ceiling as James always says and it's
true she did break the glass ceiling she
she was the first with Kay Northcott
youngest they were in their early 20s
the tech
observer women weren't doing that you
know she she was really amazing and I
could not believe that nothing had been
done on her now if she had been a man
doing what she did something may have
been done so that really sparked me and
that's actually been comments in our
social media Sarah Byrd the writer just
actually wrote a whole piece about that
and and wrote about the fact that that
she had been forgotten probably because
she had been a woman in a certain
position and she poked at the
powers-that-be you know she was
nominated three times for a Pulitzer
Prize and never got it so there's
there's that element it was who she was
I as I dug deeper into who she was and
really met so many people um there was
just the story needed to be told it was
dying to be told for Jim and Carlisle as
you did the research and you shot the
interviews and began your editing on
this did your sense of her as a
personality change well Monique's of a
tusky who is our editor we were all at
this place in the creative process and
Janice had I mean tirelessly put like
how many hours of footage together took
Carlo I mean I mean Janice I edited I
edited this for about almost five five
and a half years and then I I needed an
editor because I am an editor but I
needed distance and so Kate was
originally gonna do it with me and she
kept saying why don't you do it yourself
I said I got because I I had called it's
a calling process there was a mountain
of material it was in I mean I have a
seven I have a seven eight-hour select
reel of just Molly oh boy yeah I'm gonna
see the extras on that DVD so so but but
from your point of view and from
Carlisle's point of view as you evolved
through this process and you came to
know Molly as you came to know her
better she became a different person to
you I think for me having been a
political activist like from age you
know early on lying in the streets
during Vietnam and dealing and taught
reading who rules America and all the
issues that we were facing then and
we were willing to sacrifice so much for
her story to me embodies that that
speaking out when you don't believe that
your voice matters and I think everybody
here is an artist who has been through
this with their families or with
themselves trusting their voice and
knowing that it matters and we're doing
whatever it takes to make sure that your
voice is heard because you really do
believe that this is true and we have to
do something about it
she is so courageous speaking out about
things that we're still dealing with
today and that's why we made the film
and I think that's when we look at the
film over and over again we see that
truth to Authority to whoever it is
that's oppressing you that's that's an
important message now to youth to
everybody we are we every one of us our
voices matter and it's more important
ever that we let everybody know that and
they every one speak up the way Molly
did and that's what we're hoping people
get when they see the film so it seems
like what you wanted to do to with this
film you didn't want to end a discussion
you wanted to start one oh I'm gonna
take that one go baby sorry we did want
to start a discussion and and okay Molly
would still be writing columns and she'd
still be saying get out there and bang
the pots and pans and raise hell I mean
absolutely and it was important to all
of us that this was not just gonna be a
biopic this we wanted this to be
inspiring and get people talking and
that's what I mean
having come off of an amazing week in
Houston last weekend in Austin all
across Texas that is what's going on I
mean people are bringing their seeing
the film not once but twice in the
second time they're bringing their
nieces and their nephews and their
grandchildren and their kids and they're
talking and that was our big goal get
people talking it's a call to action
Molly tells us she looks right at us and
says you know they're scared to death of
us and all those those faces on the
front lines that they and they're all
young people they're being handed that
to this so you know it's really
important that you know your children
your grandchildren spread the word and
when I show it to him I teach I show it
to my Millennials they wanted to they
want to know who is she they're totally
fine
it up they get it well won't you thank
these hellraisers for the film